it was really hurting for a second and
now it just hurts a little bit and um
I'm doing
great hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by DOA cat she's
Grammy award-winning artist and
certified hitmaker with close to a dozen
Billboard top 10 over the years and
she's likely to add to that total with
the release of her fourth studio album
Scarlet set to drop on September 22nd
attention demons and paint the town red
the latest singles DOA cat welcome to
the show hi what's going through your
head as you prepare to take on the hot
ones Gauntlet are you at all nervous
going into this no not really I'm kind
of can I curse yeah let it fly I'm kind
of a [__] but I'm not like I don't know
I'm I'll do it to myself one
time
on the right mhm
okay
mhm thank
you thank you I'm hungry and that was
great it's great fantastic amazing we'll
take that you know I understand that the
working title previously was hellmouth
I'm curious can you pull back the
curtain on the internal calculus that
goes into naming an album like is it
something that you labor over for a long
time or is it more spontaneous than that
for sure yeah definitely it's something
where like I I don't care about the
meaning being so deep as much as the
word being a cool word I like you know I
I just like I like good words and I
thought hellmouth was
cool cuz it it meant something I forgot
what it meant uh if we Google it we can
it's like the mouth of hell you know
yeah it's like it's like a gate it's
like the gates of H but that felt so
aggressive to me after a while and I
like I don't know if I even like it
anymore and I changed my mind constantly
and Scarlet felt like the right thing to
do cuz um it's kind of an Ode to hot
pink I did a name of a color but it's
not really it's sort of like you don't
think of scarlet you think of it as like
someone's first name and not as a color
but that was kind of the twist to it and
also red is just a passionate shade of
you know color yeah that makes sense to
me all right doat you're ready to move
on here to Sauce number two yes I'm
leaking I know and then just be careful
yeah you know what I'm saying like the
cross-pollination issues here it's been
it's been awful for this this last week
I yeah I my eyes been leaking a lot good
thing here on this today it's extra
terrible so this one uh blistered
shashido and
garlic that's
fire wo I don't want to be like a
monster on camera eating these but I
might be there you go just just good
Dive Dive just dive
in what role did bananas and L mer Park
play in shaping as a young performer and
then how would you describe a typical
show for then teenage DOA cat oh my God
bananas
bananas it's just a blessing to be able
to perform for no matter how big or
small the crowd is bananas gave me that
opportunity to express myself and I've
had some shows that will haunt me for
the rest of my days and not for like any
other reason other than like my wig was
always sliding off the back of my head
and like I remember that and I like like
used to cut my wigs myself
and is there toothpick oh yeah we got we
got everything covered over here you
guys do have everything covered any sort
of uh hurdle someone has hit on this
show we try to problem solve in the
future you know love that back in the
day it was just you know it was all
about the music and I didn't you know
have the means to uh you know have a
Great Glam teen that I have today so you
know we look at you now yeah thank you
no wig at
[Music]
all this is really good I have a meal
plan I kind of I like to sort of tweak
on days and you know go back to my plan
but this is great this is our cheat meal
the cheat meal that we offer yeah
yeah so it feels fitting that you're
making your triumphant return to bars in
2023 I was really interested in a quote
that you had in a 2019 interview with L
where you said we need people are open
to doing something with theme something
with a cartoonish twist what do you see
as the role of cartoonishness in rap
music I think the correct words the the
words that I could have used that would
have been better were like campiness I
think
like when I don't know rap back in the
day was just a lot more I don't I don't
even think it's it's better now or
better then it's just like I I I get
very excited when I see rappers who um
are interested in in their visuals in a
way where they're they're ready to kind
of do something new and and twist things
and do something Camp I I feel like
Busta was a Pioneer his fashion back in
the day was just ridiculously good and
cool I don't know if he knows but he's
cool and and I feel like Missy is
another big one
um who else left ey is a big one I mean
really I feel like everybody was doing
it really really well back in the day so
I mean those are just a few that I can
name off the top of my
head it's good it kind of tastes like a
delicious
foot you know when things are Smoky or
have sort of like a yeah yeah a little
earthy little yeah yeah yeah have you
ever smelled cumin just like alone yeah
yeah it kind of smells like a foot P
pure foot it smells like body odor but
there's something kind of but it's it's
fine I want it in my
food you
know what's the key to a good vocal fry
in your opinion like from a Sound
Engineering perspective is there
anything special that goes into making
that unique DOA cat Airy
sound I feel like raspiness when talking
is frowned
upon but unless you're Joey Diaz um
um good reference when it's in music
it's great I think it's useful I think
if you
have not not everybody's voice has to be
buttery smooth and and perfect for or
whatever that means but um I don't know
I've been able to make use of of my
vocal fry I also pick and choose when to
when to use it I think my voice like
right now I don't think I have any vocal
fry but there's moments there's days
where I'm just like up here and I'm you
know an old
lady another thing that happens is if I
have headphones on and I hear myself I
can kind of take control of my voice
better I think I'm trying to be quieter
when I hear myself in my own ears and so
then my voice kind of goes here and you
get that little bit of like a fry when I
when I go lower and lower and lower and
lower but yeah since I'm talking up here
you don't get any fry
we're halfway through I'm very proud of
me you should be and
you oh yeah okay I get it yeah first
one first one if I say [__] you I don't
mean it like that it's all right I've
been uh I've been cursed out by some of
the most famous people in the world you
know and I I've become accepting of it
you know like I get it I understand it
you know
MH come on but still going in still
going back forth though yeah no no that
don't that's fine that doesn't phase me
I'm just scared for the next maybe the
the next next this one was kind of
jarring up front you know it does have
that that layer to it you know yeah the
violence I
forgot what in your opinion is the
Golden Era of music videos and if you
look through the tea leaves what do you
see as the future of making them I think
you know what it would be nice to
explore pulling back a little bit cuz I
know I I put myself through a lot of
stuff when it comes to my
visuals like attention for instance I'm
wearing jeans and a t-shirt and a jacket
and some jewelry and my makeup's not I
don't have Prosthetics I don't have a
wig I'm just me I'm very comfortable in
that video and that was such a nice
break from kind of the hell of having to
wear plastic bras and like 7 inch
platform you know what I mean so that
was really refreshing so I think you
know what as far as like the future of
my videos I do want to pull back a
little bit um but not be lazy in that
sense I'm crying I know that's the show
and it's just and it's just my left
eye and and it's on this day had to have
it on this day it's not the wings too I
know it's always How It lines up there's
no way I
know what the hell
thank
you um maybe just tissues is there t oh
amazing see we got it all I'll keep the
mirror and I'll bring it back to you
when we're
done
[Music]
[__] whiskey smoked
ghost should be fair yeah there's an
even dispersal there's a very even
dispersal yeah yeah we we care about the
little big things here you know I
remember back in the
day it used to be they dab it on there
and like a little there'd be a little
puddle of the sauce in the center of a
be Wing that used to hurt my soul I'm
glad that you guys have come this far
wow so you're like back back way back
yeah yeah I've been watching this I I'm
addicted to the internet right yeah yeah
what's like your weirdest YouTube rabbit
hole you think um oh man I love this
question I also hate it cuz I can't
think of there's so many things um I was
on a a Steve wios uh shout out the
legend vendor YouTube poop has a lot of
interesting I feel YouTube poop on game
do you know what YouTube poop is no no
no no idea so it's a sub genre of
YouTube comedy and it involves
taking I I like it most when it's a talk
show and you go in and edit it to make
it sound like someone's saying something
that's like super like crass and like
crazy and like like there's some uh Dr
Phil YouTube poops out there that are
some of the best ones and uh I keep
going back to them but it's a very deep
rabbit hole and there's a lot lot of bad
ones that aren't funny at
all that's good it's
chill it's about to hit me it's one of
yeah that's the thing sometimes is is
you talk about them and it's almost like
they hear you you know
yep
yeah how's my lipstick is it okay it's
not doing that buildup on the inside of
the
lips all right
right [__] we here at first we Feast we
were really excited to read in a 2021
cover story that you did with rolling
stone that you dream doing a cooking
show in the vein of Action Bronson [__]
that's delicious do you have an elevator
pitch because you know you have a home
here if you still need one um I really
wanted to do a cooking show but I got so
much [__] going on I know I know I got
to I want to make music like I I love to
cook love to cook they make fun of me
all the time when I cook cuz the way I
cook I cook like a cartoon
character I like I'm kind of
extra um but yeah I wanted to do a show
cuz I was making these sandwiches it was
like like wagu and Grier and stuff oh
yeah oh [__] okay so yes so people know
about it I was making these sandwiches
and they're really good they're really
rich but it's kind of the only amazing
thing I know how to make all right DOA
cat this is the moment when you walked
in you were like is the bomb here yeah
there's a reputation that
precedes and it is that time mommy yeah
don't say yourself are you going to bite
into it yeah I'm just going to dive in
this is the kind this is there's a
there's a threshold and I'm not stalling
there's a threshold of you where where
pepper is like a delicious flavor each
pepper is unique and has an amazing new
flavor to it and then there's the
peppers that all taste the same cuz they
all taste like hot dirt
yeah well I think this one might
exclusively use hot dirt P I don't even
need to bite do I have to bite into this
I don't even need to bite into this I'm
Already There
bye-bye
you there we go there we go game phase
on penis [__] and the party has
[Music]
started that's good
it doesn't get worse than that what are
you talking
about ask me questions all right so you
know one of my great favorite Simple
Pleasures in life is running a frozen
eucalyptus towel over my head oh my
[Music]
goodness you've had the bomb before yeah
many fck [__] you up yeah every time
the discomfort that you feel
the discomfort that you're going through
I catch it every single time you
know what was the question okay one of
the great Simple Pleasures in my life is
running a frozen eucalyptus towel over
my head after a long workout and I
really kind of pity people who will
never know the feeling what to you so
far has been the most welcome benefit of
going
ball
so I like what I like most about it is I
can focus on what I'm wearing and less
about my hair mhm so I've been able to
like I don't know it's just like hair is
another it's a whole other world it's a
whole other situation it's like you got
to braid it and piggy tails and [__]
like
that it's like [__] that I could just do
a cute outfit and be bald like there's a
hell of bad [__] that are bald in
this
world like why would I have to do hair
all the time this is not so bad after a
while right once you kind of settle into
it and
uh I don't know if you're catching it m
but I can get kind of a
weightlessness sort of head high mhm
that I think is been easier to shake
loose the more I do it so now pretty
much every single episode I get high at
about this time on yeah I you know what
I know you're I know what you're talking
about ow I know what you're talking
about cuz it was really hurting for a
second and now it just hurts a little
bit and um I'm doing
[Music]
great I'm 5'3 I'm only one man
yeah double
fisting I don't know what I want more
you're right Sophie's Choice here yeah
so I know that you game and flex that a
Nintendo where you shouted out
everything from spiral to Mortal Kombat
Super Smash Bros and even had the
GameCube startup music on Loop you just
seem like the right person to ask which
video game do you think has the best
original
music ah okay so I got two well well I
like Crash Bandicoot soundtra music my
favorite is Barbie on GameCube I sampled
it one time and it's a genie Barbie like
Genie game on GameCube and it's so good
but like I think you're a mermaid for
some of it you're on a carpet and you're
flying and it's so [__] dope and that
yeah the music is amazing and it's all
that 8 bit sound but it's like these
amazing ensembles of
8bit gleaked a little bit 8bit uh sound
and it's it's amazing let's play one's
got to go cult classic game Edition okay
okay okay Fusion frenzy Oddworld Abes
Odyssey earthworm gem what about it I
won all of those games I know but you
got to kick one out I'm kicking out
Fusion frenzy just cuz it makes me upset
that game is very hard the the computer
like the the NPCs are too smart like
they're too good I think they [__] up
in that
game it's me at this point okay
yes
I'm just going to do it I respect
it yeah that's smart that's smart that's
smart little puddle is it that it's that
crazy so it is hot I'm just hedging I'm
just hedging I mean it's the 10th one
you
[Music]
know Cheers Cheers what a
ride and there it
goes did you
lie it has a little bit of a timer on it
you lied though hitten right now H right
now that's fair going through us like a
wave it's going to it makes the show you
know better cool and fun to watch and
you are crushing it still on your feet
both of us right now slaying a hot sauce
beast from within which is actually a
rather poetic segue to this last hurdle
cuz in an interview that you did last
year with da you revealed another hyphen
it to your many hyphens as an
Entertainer when you said I love to
paint monsters that's my favorite thing
so I'll doodle a monster and then put it
on big canvas it's been an interesting
process so with that in mind I realized
that this is kind of a tall ask given
where we are in the show but we have a
little sketch pad and a pencil and we
would be so honored if you would maybe
give us a monster doodle inspired by
your experience with the wings of death
today oh my God God this is
fun
thanks it's the least we can
do yeah I can do
[Music]
some
[__] yeah that's not as bad as to bomb
it's still really [__]
terrible it sucks yeah I know I get I'm
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry it's a show I
have to apologize for oh my God no I
mean it's a brilliant
show
how long do do you want me to take with
this do I have 10 minutes do I have five
minutes take you take it wherever you
want to go because you know we got a
little fade cross fade in the edit you
know it'll move take your time do
whatever you got to do with it love
that you're going to like this I can
tell I know already I don't know you
very well but I think you'll like
this do like a
o all right
shit's in my
[Music]
throat all right this is my monster no
actually [__] that here I'm going to
actually make it scary I'm going to
color his eyes in I think that's what it
[Music]
needed that's dope I think he's cute a
masterpiece if I've ever seen one hang
it in the lbe and look at you cat taking
on the wings of death and living to tell
the tale and now there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet for you
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life I got a tour coming up it's
called The Scarlet
tour um let me put this [__] down close
this book I got the Scarlet tour coming
up and I got uh what else do I got going
on I got my album coming out on the
22nd of September is it this month is it
September yet mhm okay and and um that's
basically
it thank
you thank you you did
[Music]
it hot hot hot
hot hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans and if you would like
to get your hands I'm the Season 22 hot
Ones hot sauce lineup at this point you
know the drill heatness.com heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands on
the hot ones Season 22 hot sauce lineup
ice cream not included be careful around
the eyes don't say I didn't warn you